[Musique]
c'est l'image que Marine Le Pen espérait
depuis des jours coup de théâtre en 2017
vous vous rangez aux côtés de Marine Le
Pen présidente de la République je
nommerai Nicolas Dupont-Aignan Premier
ministre de la France je persiste et je
signe marine de Pen n'a rien à voir avec
Jean-Marie Le Pen et vous n'auriez
jamais eu une image avec moi et
Jean-Marie Le Pen c'est une sorte de je
sais pas si Marine aime le terme parce
que chacun sa culture chacun son mais
Comité de salut public pour sauver le
pays c'est parce qu'on avait en face de
nous Emmanuel Macron qui est le
fossoyeur de la France et qui est
l'homme des oligarques avec des gens
d'horizon différents bah voilà on se
retrouve et on va sauver notre pays mais
c'est extraordinaire ce que nous vivons
ce matin Emmanuel Macron rassemblant les
mondialistes obligatoirement les
patriotes même de gauche et de droite
seront obligés de se rassembler je n'ai
pas un mot à retirer d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant ces images
[Musique]